one of the invaders approached me like
he was going to try to get past me
and head down the stairs i hit him
knocking him down
i told him to just leave the capitol and
in response they yelled
no man this is our house president trump
invited
us here we're here to stop this deal
joe biden is not the president nobody
voted for joe biden
i'm a law enforcement officer and i do
my best to keep politics out of my job
but in this circumstance i responded
well i voted for joe biden does my vote
not count
am i nobody
that prompted a torrent of racial
epithets
one woman in a pink mega shirt yelled
you hear that guys this voted for joe
biden
then the crowd perhaps around 20 people
joined in screaming boom
no one had ever ever
called me while wearing the uniform of a
capitol police officer
in the days following the attempted
insurrection
other black officers shared with me
their own stories of racial abuse on
january 6.
one officer told me he had never
and in his his entire 40 years of life
been caught to his face and that streak
ended on january 6. yet
another black officer later told me he
had been
confronted by insurrectionists in the
capitol
who told him put your gun down
and we'll show you what kind of you
really are
at one point i came face to face with an
attacker who repeatedly lunged for me
and attempted to remove my firearm
i heard chanting from some in the crowd
get his gun
and kill him with his own gun
i was aware enough to recognize i was at
risk of being stripped of
and killed with my own firearm i was
electrocuted
again and again and again
with a taser what makes the struggle
harder
and more painful is to know so many of
my fellow citizens including so many of
the people i put my life
at risk to defend are downplaying or
outright denying
what happened the indifference
shown to my colleagues is disgraceful
to my perpetual confusion i saw the thin
blue line flag
a symbol of support for law enforcement
more than once being carried by the
terrorists as they ignored our commands
and continued to assault us
the mob of terrorists were coordinating
their efforts now shouting heave
ho as they synchronize pushing their
weight forward crushing you further
against the middle door frame
man in front of me grabbed my baton that
i still held in my hands in my current
state i was unable to retain my weapon
he bashed me in the head and faced with
it rupturing my lip and adding
additional injury to my skull
i too was being crushed by the riders i
could feel my
myself losing oxygen and recall thinking
to myself
this is how i'm going to die defending
this entrance
we did not receive timely reinforcement
and support we needed in contrast
during the black lives matter's protest
last year u.s capitol police had
all the support we needed and more
there are some who express our age when
someone
kneels while calling for social justice
where are those same people expressing
the outrage to condone
condemn the violence attack on law
enforcement
the capital in our american democracy
i'm still waiting for them